with doctor strange and the multiverse
of madness officially in theaters much
is being said about sam raimi's return
to the genre he's had such an
everlasting impact on but you may recall
that sam raimi was not always the
director of this film multiverse of
madness was originally slated to be
directed by scott derrickson who also
directed the 2016 film that marked the
character's introduction into the mcu
however in the beginning of 2020 scott
derrickson and marvel studios parted
ways and cited the ever so nebulous
creative differences as the reason so
now is a good time as any to revisit the
2016 film our source for the information
in this video is the director's
commentary scott said he had over eight
meetings with marvel studios to land the
film in fact he did a 90-minute
presentation and wrote a 12-page script
with this sequence as part of his pitch
doctor strange clearly uses the visual
effects from inception as inspiration
but what you may not know is that the
other sources of inspiration was the
work of dutch artists m.c escher and
german expressionist